check out harry styles and olivia wilde
walking hand in hand that's right that
is right now a source tells et that they
couldn't be happier my advice is go be
awesome just be awesome and the right
people will be attracted to you for who
you are that's the former one direction
singer strolling down the street in
london with a 38 year old actress
olivia rocking shades a blue and white
striped button down under a light blue
sweater which she paired with jeans and
sneakers as for harry he's sporting
black sunglasses a blue bomber jacket
and a white tee with ripped jeans and
that right there that's some serious
handholding
now a source tells et that things are
pretty serious between the lovebirds
adding quote they're well past the crush
and infatuation phase and are solid
partners they're the real deal of course
the two first sparked romance rumors
back in 2021 when they were photographed
holding hands at a wedding but before
that olivia cast terry in don't worry
darling a film she directed i enjoyed
the experience a lot at the time a
source told et that the two were
inseparable quote that's in part because
they've been in a bubble for their film
but even in the days since it wrapped
they're still spending all their time
together if you do admire someone just
know
that you being yourself completely is
what will draw them to you
now a source tells et that while they
have pretty busy schedules and a lot of
personal commitments they make a point
to prioritize time with each other it's
a balance adding that they are pretty
low-key and just love spending time
together along with their families and
friends
and speaking of family the source adds
that the watermelon sugar singer's mom
loves olivia and her kids quote their
families have blended so seamlessly i
was like this is remarkable not many
people can do that olivia shares two
children with her ex jason sedakis
seven-year-old otis and five-year-old
daisy
i think we did a humdinger of a job the
two confirmed their split in november
2020 after seven years together of
course jason's hit show ted lasso is
currently in production in the united
kingdom and their kids are big fans
they have seen ted lasso otis refers to
roy kent as the king of the f word
king of the f i think is what he says
don't you fret my fine furry fella in a
matter of minutes your relationship
dilemma will be in the past where i'm
rounding up the diamond dogs
who the [ __ ] are the diamond dogs
no no i mean he
no okay he used to
we got we we got him off that we got
that but uh but yeah they've they've
watched it more otis than daisy uh for i
mean because
a four and a half year old you know but
a seven-year-old yeah he's good to go
yeah he's our rated yeah he gets it and
given that harry is from the uk et
source says it's basically home-based
for all of them which works well for
everyone
i've got no complaints this is my dream
come true
[Music]
you